this is about family well in the rock to
let shooting this movie doesn t
understand my financial issues guys we
have to shoot this quickly and
aggressively
don't you mean fast and furiously 9 so
here's the deal we're shooting this
intro at 9:30 in the morning because I
have jury duty I can't talk about any
specifics it's gonna be an ongoing trial
who knows how long this is gonna last
loser
civic duty but I got an hour and 15
minute lunch break so I am jetting back
here to shoot this reaction and review
with John immediately jetting back to
jury duty I don't have jury duty on
Sunday and Sunday is Super Bowl Sunday
so please subscribe and click that
notification bell because ya best
believe are gonna be covering so much
that days you're gonna want to get
notified when we got a reaction up for
the trailer or whatever that you're
looking forward to
let's hit the nos and drive vanya intro
decelerator
[Music]
let's do this just like Tony Stark
that's why wearing the wife beater by
the way you seen people on it I love you
3000 rpms I look like him when I was a
boy follow me
it's a good good that's a tiny guns into
a car
Oh John Cena cyber VidCon she discovered
at the dredge yeah she got a mohair this
is connected to the Hobbs and char
universe
and hammers great yeah looks like
they've beefed up the travel action
oh hey Dan the hand handlers great yeah
oh there we go
it's the same I love what they did
hostage shot yeah there's gonna be a
haka somewhere rocket con they are good
yeah oh wow I'm so happy what justice
for Han
that was great never would have expected
that what ustus what a great surprise
there for justice for Han on of justice
everyone's like don't worry guys
justice for Han will eventually come and
he's gonna bring the justice himself how
they're gonna explain this I will buy
whatever answer they have I'm just glad
he's back he's got some short hair I can
work with that man Lettie way back he'll
have a little amnesia in there yeah so
this idea of with Jacob is John Cena's
character's name yeah in the NED word
and there's a whole love triangle with
Vindi I think that was it I didn't quite
catch it that's a nice turn of events
here there's so much to the fast and
furious is about family right that's
like the big most of big theme of it and
it seems like we're gonna get a lot more
focus on Lettie and Dawn the
relationship they have a kid that's
great they'll pass the baton on to that
child and fast 15 protective cross via
vampires break-in in a subplot hope this
movie ends with a time jump right to
when that kid is all grown up and he's
doing the exact same crap that would be
a total blast you know like everyone in
the family if I'm not mistaken is not
real blood related it's an interesting
conflict it wouldn't be possible for
them all to be right but I'll say it's
an interesting conflict yet to have John
Cena be his actual blood brother that
the enemy is his blood brother and then
his family are non blood I think is an
interesting dichotomy to be in and then
you're gonna get two villains in this
one you're gonna get Charlize Theron's
cipher you're gonna get John Cena's
Jacob and then once you have the
staredown base that you got to have yeah
yeah here I'm like okay I see how that
casts John Cena my prediction if this is
gonna go down the path of all the other
Fast & Furious movies John Cena will
eventually become a part of the fast
family and he'll just be a good guy
oh yeah you can't kill dumbs brother
alright they're not happy what he
wouldn't do that
Dom wanted yeah and then either
something bigger will cross Jacob and
then they'll have to team up or yeah
they'll beat out their family
differences and come back together even
stronger than ever before and then you
know this fray the
we'll just keep growing but ya know like
we kept commenting on the trailer like
the action looked a really superb yeah
like the Hannah ham and also some of the
just the car Destruction stunts looked
really good it looked like they're kind
of going back to a more slightly
grounded for this universe take because
the last couple have gotten so huge and
so wacky and this looked a little more
even though there's an exotic location
or know if I call it grounded because it
looks like they're going more on like
locations they're on this like coastal
jungle area stuff and they're off the
street are hovering with your problems
exactly and then they're in that like
big metal tube with all the catwalks
right off and it looks like they are
going especially down that espionage
like a Jason Bourne influence or a James
Brown didn't fluence some of that John
wick and the hand-to-hand stuff well the
other part that I really picked up on
was the emphasis female powered this
film its whoa what the hell I mean yes
which side do I take I choose yay for
woman I thought there was gonna be a
rhyme there there wasn't but a lot of
the Hanahan action is seem to go a lot
to the ladies in this one Michelle
Rodriguez Jordana Brewster home so happy
is here taken a lot of ass it's cool
that like our two female characters and
the main ones are both moms then they
get to kick a lot of butt in this
trailer
a lot of bootay and then Hannah looks
better than the Hobbes and Shaw Hannah
ham which was something I was really
looking forward to because of that
director but this looks to be out doing
it but come on Han is back that's the
main takeaway han is bad you know it is
and the only other thing I'm wondering
is they tuck that baby in and then they
just left to go out on a death - I'm
sure like watching the bait baby will be
involved in the action in the finale I
see it coming have you seen a baby
kicking ass will you will and you know
part of my concern was some we're gonna
miss the presence of the characters of
Hobbs and Shaw and I don't I I thought
this really did a great job John Cena
maybe he'll get BTS on the soundtrack I
gotta get back to George jump on it go
alright guys well I got a jet back but
what did you think of this Fast and
Furious 9 trailer what got you the most
excited for it do you still feel like
this
franchise has fuel left in the tank to
keep on going whatever subscribe click
that notification Bell joined the reject
family and get accepted also make sure
to download a false in the Stardust app
over there with you 30 second reviews
for any film TV show and/or trailer we
post quite a lot actually community over
there's been great growing a lot last
but not least I would like to end this
with a patron of the day shout out to a
lovely beautiful woman named Lynn a
Lynnae I got to give you a personal
thank you I recently got to watch Jon
and I both at the Royal Rumble at dead
meat James's party it was a total blast
e-blast and I was able to keep up with
so much of what was going on primarily
because of the introductions you have
given us over time I was able to follow
all of it you've influenced our lives in
so many ways especially like that also I
let my girlfriend wear the shirt that
you gave me and it earned her some
instant likability points
John and then someone hit Greg over the
back with a chair and I laughed about it
yep way to make it about lenay much love
lenay i love you love me my dear hope
your new year is going great and that
you were able to fulfill whatever 2020
resolutions you got left in store
bodyslam them